Michael how can i leverage content to
increase my search engine optimization
another great question you know what SEO
first came out everybody wanted to
create content that was filled with all
kinds of search terms and as a result it
kind of diminished the quality of
content that people were producing you
would find a lot of articles that were
just sometimes just didn't even make
sense I remember my first marketing job
and we had some blog posts that were
questionable because they were written
for you know a search engine they
weren't written for the person who's
actually going to be reading that
content so it's important to kind of
keep that in mind that you know when
you're taking into consideration writing
for SEO you have to remember that it's
it's a balance because the ultimate goal
is to educate your your customers
educate your audience and so it can be
easy to let the SEO take over that but
there are a lot of ways that you can use
SEO to kind of help bolster your posts
as well so for example you know working
at a weber we want to rank for email
marketing so we often include the term
email marketing in our blog posts and
but it's a matter of you know really
understanding like where it's a perp and
making sure that it makes sense and that
you're still providing value to to your
audience yeah the advice I gave us is
what advice Google gives basically which
is right for people don't write for the
search engines right for the people and
so you know if I'm typing in email
marketing as a search term and that's
something that you want to get rank for
then I expect to be given a page it
provides me value about email marketing
so you might come up with a list of 50
different keywords that you're trying to
rank for with each one of those keywords
don't just write something that's 300
words and slap it up and you know you
mentioned that word 10 times and you
hope you get it rank for it that used to
work like way way way all the way back
but not anymore you want to write for
the audiences so I'm typing that in you
know if I'm typing in salsa classes
Toronto I want to find on that page that
I hit relevant information about salsa
classes in Toronto and it's okay to have
a promo on a call to action and
here's your next step but the content
that you give me has to be value I and
not just a sales pitch and not just
something written for robots so that's
what I would do basically look at every
search every trying to rank for and then
create content that would be genuinely
interesting for someone who had that
question yeah and definitely to add on
to that too if there are a variety of
search terms that you want to rank for
that's a great place to you know help
brainstorm some blog content as well or
video content you know you can have a
video that addresses one key phrase you
can have a blog that addresses another
so that really helps you know extend the
life of your blog post it gives you new
ideas for your content which is actually
which is really helpful to you yeah and
if you're spending all the time and
making a video you can also turn those
into blog posts i know you guys do that
anyway where you take ideas from your
blog and turn into videos and vice versa
you're spending so much time creating
the energy and investment to make you
one piece of content you can leverage
out in a lot of different ways you can
turn those into tweets that you send out
over facebook pictures or videos and
vice versa if you spend a lot of time
making a video you could take the
transcript and turn it into a blog
article and take out the arms and ahhs
and all that stuff so you'll use your
content use it as a multi-purpose
vehicle to help continually drive more
traffic to your site